اجتماع خلال الاسبوع الجاري في
فيينا. وساد التفاؤل ايضا في
مدرستها انتقاما لها. النار اتت
على كامل ملفات الطلبة وغرفتي
ان الصين كثفت من اقمارها
الصناعية في الفترة الاخيرة
الاوروبيون متفائلون للتوصل
باحياء الاتفاق النووي ويتحدثون
الاقمار الصناعية في مقاطعة
بجنوب غربي البلاد. الم تلاحظوا
صناعيا جديدا اسمته ستة عشر الى
الفضاء وذلك من مركز لاطلاق
وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي ان اي
هجوم لحزب الله اللبناني على
الحب لما رسبت. اليس كذلك?
الاستخبارات الروسية تدخل لندن
بينما تعلن عن قاعدة امريكية
جديدة في مياه الخليج فبماذا
الحكومة بوقف مد كييف بالاسلحة.
شاب مصري رسبت خطيبته فاحرق
سمح الله بل تتمهل ولتحكم عقولكم
قبل ان يقع الفأس في الرأس.
الجزائر بعدما اكتشف ثغرة امنية
خطيرة في نظامها الامني. قال
لاوكرانيا للتصدي لروسيا. شركة
ابل الامريكية تكرم هاكرين من
بعد اخر يستمر العراق في
الانجرار نحو اتون حرب اهلية لا
زيارته لمصر والعودة الى بلاده
لمتابعة تطورات الاحداث ودعا الى
العميري رئيس مجلس الوزراء
العراقي مصطفى الكاظمي قرر قطع
الاعتصام امام المجلس سيستمر حتى
تحقيق لائحة مطالب من بينها حل
بالتصرفات غير الدستورية
والمخالفة للقانون اعلن مجلس
الواقع? يا له من امر عجيب وغريب
حقا. العراق يختنق العراق يغلي
اجتماع فوري لقيادات القوى
السياسية لنزع فتيل الازمة. يوما
بحق قياديين اثنين في التيار
الصدري وهما صباح السعدي وغيب
برلمان وعدم تسييس القضاء حيث
اصدرت محكمة عراقية مذكرة اعتقال
بالتاريخي حيث اعلنت شركة لوكيد
مورتن الامريكية للدفاع انها
قدرته ستين كيلو واط يمكن زيادته
الى مائة وعشرين كيلو واط. فهل
سترد موسكو برأيكم هل سيستعين
بوتين بايران ليعلن عن تواجده
القضاء الاعلى تعليق عمل المجلس
والمحاكم التابعة له والمحكمة
للتجارة في جميع انحاء المنطقة
والممرات الاستراتيجية. فبماذا
في الخليج العربي دورنا الاساسي
مهم هو ضمان حرية التدفق الحر
السوريين? اعلان عسكري امريكي.
وسط غليان على اكثر من جبهة
في ظل هذه الازمة السياسية
الخانقة احتجاجا على ما وصفها
يعود بنا الزمن الى ايام الطفولة
لنشاهد مسلسل هزيم الرعد على
ستعمل على تزويد السفن الحربية
باسلحة الليزر التكتيكية عبر
المدير والاداريين. ربما لو
تركتها تركز على دراستها بدلا من
واشنطن باسقاط طهران مطالب
رئيسية. بهدف الدعوة للسلام ومنع
عن ردود عقلانية من ايران على
مسودهم للاتفاق وترتيبات لعقد
نشوب الحرب العالمية الثالثة
المان يجمعون تواقيع تطالب
الاحداث والتطورات. ماكرون
مستعدون لدعم طويل المدى
منصة الغاز كريش سيفجر حربا في
لبنان اطلقت الصين بنجاح قمرا
الاتحادية العليا. التيار الصدري
وصف التعليق بالمعيب مؤكدا ان
انه ليست لدى انقرة اي شروط
مسبقة للحوار مع سوريا فماذا عن
شخص لننتقل الى حفيد عثمان والذي
صرح قائلا هدفنا هو عقد لقاء بين
السيد بوتين والسيد زالنسكي في
وقت ليس ببعيد في تركيا بهدف فتح
حوادث العنصرية ضدهم هل يقطع
اردوغان حبال الود مع اللاجئين
اوغلو ان هناك حوارا يجري بين
اجهزة السورية والتركية واضاف
الى الملف السوري. حيث صرح وزير
الخارجية التركي مولود شاووش
واوكرانيا. وانها لن تسمح
بانتهاك العقوبات من جانب اي او
اربعة ملايين لاجئ سوري فمع
انهيار الاقتصاد التركي وتصاعد
تركيا في تخطي العقوبات الغربية
المفروضة على موسكو. جاء هذا في
الادارة الامريكية ان كيانات
وافراد من روسيا يحاولون استخدام
سلاح ليزر جديد يدعى هيليوس ويعد
هليوس سلاح الليزر عالي الطاقة
العسكري في مياه الخليج? هنا
اعلان امريكي عسكري وصف
بحلول صيف الفين وثلاثة وعشرين.
واضاف قائد الاسطول الذي يتمركز
منصة غير مأهولة للطائرات
المسيرة في منطقة الشرق الاوسط
التركي. وهنا ترد انقرة ببيان
رسمي من وزارة المالية التركية
اتصال هاتفي اجراه نائب وزيرة
الخزانة الامريكية مع الجانب
من الضعف خلال العام الجاري رغم
العقوبات الغربية ليأتي الرد في
الشمالية ليصل الرد من موسكو
اسرع من بيونج يانج. اذ ****
الاسطول الامريكي الخامس براد
كوبر ان بلاده تعتزم نشر مائة
لنشر مائة منصة للمسيرات في
الخليج لردع التهديدات اعلن قائد
دولية ارتفاع وتيرة التهديدات
النووية. الجيش الامريكي يخطط
مؤكدة على عمق العلاقات
الاقتصادية والسياسية مع روسيا
الطريق امام ايجاد حل جذري لهذه
الحرب. ومن ملف اوكرانيا المشتعل
تصريح امريكي تفوح منه رائحة
التخوين لتركيا. حيث نبهت
يحاولون التسلل الى داخل مصنع
اسلحة. ومن لندن الى اصوات
النفط الروسي. تركيا ترفع
استيرادها من النفط الروسي باكثر
بالاملاءات والهيمنة الخارجية.
فماذا تقصد العبارة يا حفيد
بوتين يتحدث قائلا. بلادي قوة
عالمية قوية ومستقلة ولن تسمح
بانها تكتيك استفزازي وفي ذكرى
عيد العلم الوطني الروسي هنا
في تجاهل الخطوط الحمراء التي
حددتها موسكو لتخطفنا الاحداث
الاحتفال بذكرى الاستقلال. وذلك
خشية من هجوم روسي وصفته بالدموي
المتحدة تدريبات عسكرية مشتركة
منتظمة هي الاشرس. وذلك بهدف
نشرت صحيفة البريطانية احتمالية
وجود اكثر من الف جاسوس يستهدف
حذر فيه الرئيس الاوكراني من
اجراء روسي استفزازي في عيد
عن نيتها لحرب قادمة مع هذه
الدولة فيما ابل تكرم هكرا
استالين. تركيا تكسب ود روسيا.
بينما تتقشف اوروبا كي تتخلص من
مجلس الامن الروسي واصفا
المناورات العسكرية لواشنطن وسول
تعزيز الدفاع ضد التهديدات
النووية والصاروخية المتطورة
المدافع وازيز الطائرات. حيث
بدأت كوريا الجنوبية والولايات
احتمالية حدوث صدام عسكري مع دول
حلف الناتو في حال تمادت واستمرت
هذا التسريب سهوا حيث تقرير
استخبارات عسكرية ان روسيا تكدس
المملكة المتحدة. ويأتي هذا بعد
القبض على ثلاثة جواسيس روس وهم
الاكثر سخونة وتوجهنا الى
بريطانيا وبالتحديد لندن حيث
لبوتين. والعراق يختنق فهل يحكم
العراقيون عقولهم واسرائيل تعلن
المجنون من جديد. وتركيا تكسب ود
روسيا واوكرانيا تعلن عن فاجعة
موسكو بهذا التصريح؟ روسيا تنتقم
من بريطانيا بينما واشنطن تزعج
بعدم تجاهل الخطوط الحمراء. هكذا
قالتها روسيا فما الذي تقصده
نحن نحذر من حدوث تصادم عسكري
وشيك مع دول حلف الناتو وننصحهم
جزائرية. روسيا وحلف الناتو. في
حرب الاستخبارات العالمية سقط
صواريخ في بيلاروس استعدادا لشن
هجوم كبير على اوكرانيا. في وقت
عسكرية قادمة عسكري امريكي من
وسط الخليج العربي يتسبب بصدمة
وذلك نقلا عن موقع وهنا نائب
وزير الخارجية الروسي يحذر من
استقلال اوكرانيا لتظهر هنا
اوكرانيا وتعلن عن الغاء
سترد موسكو?